alright so in this video I want to talk
a little bit more about the structural
details of collagen
okay so let's bring up some notes here
that we can fill in okay so collagen is
a triple stranded helix okay and that
triple stranded helix is specifically
called troppo collagen okay and that
triple collagen looks something like
this okay so each of those different
colored strands this little yellow one
this purple one in this sort of greenish
one they're all wrapped around each
other and they end up making some sort
of rope okay so that's what that's
tropocollagen right there now so that's
three polypeptides that are wound very
tightly around each other in a roguelike
fashion okay and each of those each
polypeptide is an alpha chain okay now
each of those alpha chains consists at
least mostly of these little triplet
repeats of amino acids okay so they are
basically it's glycine and then X and
then Y okay where x and y represent
other amino acids now X is typically or
for the most part a prolene okay and
that allows tight kinks to form
specifically so so this X right here
would typically be prolene and it's
helpful that it's right next to glycine
because glycine is a really really tight
assuming it really really small amino
acid it's the smallest amino acid
because its side chain is simply a
hydrogen so having a prolene right next
to it and if you're familiar with
protein structure you're near that
prolene having that that side chain that
comes back and is bound to its alpha
nitrogen its alpha amino nitrogen I
should say form forms little bends in
polypeptide chains and so here when it's
right next when that prolene is right
next to glycine it allows tight kinks to
form because because glycine doesn't
sterically hindered it okay so that's
pretty important it allows the the
triple stranded helix to whine really
really tightly around each other okay
those three polypeptides and the Y is
typically hydroxyproline or
hydroxylysine
okay hydroxy prolene or hydroxylysine so
what are hydroxyproline in hydroxylysine
they're just prolene and lysine residues
that have hydroxyl groups attached to
them okay and the the hydroxylation of
those prolene and lysine residues occurs
in the rough endoplasmic reticulum and
that hydroxylation process requires
ascorbic acid or a score bait which is
also called vitamin c okay
vitamin C I'll just abbreviate that here
as vite C as a cofactor and a deficiency
in that vitamin C actually causes a
disease called scurvy and I'll talk a
little bit more about that definitely
later in the series and I'll mention it
here a little bit but what does a
hydroxylation of those residues look
like looks like this okay so here we
have a prolene residue or a pro lleol
residue part of a polypeptide chain so
prolyl hydroxylase with using vitamin c
as a cofactor will go through and attach
a hydroxy a hydroxyl group to to the
prolene creating hydroxy the HUD
hydroxyproline or hydroxyproline has to
do and the same sort of thing can happen
for lysine so here we have a side chain
of lysine lysyl hydroxylase will act on
it add the hydroxyl group there okay so
we create the hydroxy lysyl or
hydroxylysine residue okay now that's
important because these are these o h
groups they they exist on this
polypeptide strand okay so here I didn't
go through and draw this but here
there's that you know that triplet
repeat there's glycine and an X and a Y
and then there's a glycine and an X and
a Y and you can imagine that occurs
throughout this whole chain here and
this whole chain back there and this one
here and those residues it when they're
when they have hydroxylated side chains
Oh H groups will be kind of here and
here there'll be all age groups all over
this thing and those o H groups can
hydrogen bond with other Oh H groups and
are on the other
polypeptides and so that is really
important in maining maintaining the
structural integrity of collagen okay
that's called cross-linking that's one
type of cross-linking in in collagen and
that like I said it holds the chains
together and so when when patients have
vitamin C deficiency again I'll talk
more about it later but that compromises
the structural integrity of of collagen
and the connective tissue in those
individuals and that that that is scurvy
okay I've got more on that later okay so
when it comes to collagen it's not just
this this triple helix okay
there's there's it's not just those
fibers connected to each other and being
held together like that it's more
there's more to it than that there are
these little these this triple helix
ends up being represented sometimes by
this little bar shown here and what ends
up happening is that troppo collagen
will end up kind of arranging itself
with a bunch of other tropocollagen and
they'll be held together to form mature
collagen which actually looks like this
okay and so that forms bring up some
stuff here okay that forms mature
collagen and mature collagen
you